[Music]
[Applause]
what is up guys I am so excited to be
back and I will be starting to make
videos a lot more regularly because now
I am back at home and my internet is
slowly getting better we will soon have
better internet so I can start making
videos a lot quicker and a lot better so
anyways let's get start into the video
so today we're going to be buying
Dragonstone amulets and making them into
glories using the enchantment spell
which does require 68 magic and we are
going to be buying cosmic runes and a
mud battle stuff so we don't have to use
water and earth runes because that will
cost more and take much longer so right
here I am buying the drawing stone
amulet for the highest price and selling
it for the lowest price to get the
margins the plan is to buy it for the
lowest price and then I'm doing the same
thing with the glory so I can kind of
get an idea of how much money we're
going to make per glory in the future
okay so I have the margins
get the cosmic ruin margin as well
all right
so go to the calculator
so if I sold it for the max price which
is 18,000
and I - the minimum price all will
probably go hundred over just in case
- the Kazakh room
okay so that's over 1,000 so I will go
ahead and put in an offer for 16 700
I could buy them for a little bit
cheaper but I'm trying to buy them a
little quicker so we'll go ahead and put
an offer for let's see how much it up by
display that many
all right now I'm waiting for that I'll
go ahead and buy the cosmic runes I
won't buy them for the max price because
the dragon stones would take a little
bit so I may as well make these wait all
right so I'll be back so after a few
minutes the causing runes obviously sold
instantly but the dragon stone are
taking a little bit too long so I'm
going to go ahead and up the price right
after I buy the mud battle stuff because
we're going to need that later so let's
see what we bought them for okay well
I'm just going to go ahead and put the
price up to sixteen nine hundred and
then I'll buy 150 two of them to make an
even 160 and I'll be back when these
sell so these were taking a little too
long to sell so I figured someone was
undercutting me and they were I guess
somewhere undercutting me there if
anything they're over cutting me and
they're buying them for sixteen nine
hundred fifty so I decided to go ahead
and up with Christ by three GP and co
sold so a couple of them sold pretty
quickly but they're taking too long so I
wait overnight and then they sold so now
I will go ahead and chant them so
basically I do you Bank them take them
out clicking in chant spell and just
click them over and over and I start at
the timer here and I kept this video
going because I'm on do you guys see
that I didn't cheat on the time and now
we will wait for them to be done and
then we will calculate the prices how
long it took and how much magic
experience we get per hour
[Music]
I
[Applause]
alright I'm done in two five minutes and
23 seconds so we'll go ahead and round
that's 5 and 1/2 minutes so it takes
five and half minutes to do 150 of them
sorry I have the hiccups and now I will
go ahead and sell them get the margins
and see how much we can sell them for so
I figure out the margins and I can still
sell them for 18,000 so we'll go ahead
and sell them for that and I will come
back when they sell and I'll show you
how much money we make per hour so take
a little bit of time but they did sell
doesn't take that long so I did the math
of what we spent because I don't have
the history anymore because I did some
alkene in-between so I went ahead and
wrote it down there so now we will do
the cosmic runes how much they cost
because about 150 of them times 134 so
twenty thousand one hundred so 20
thousand one hundred and we will add the
cost of all the dragon stone amulets
that we bought so two million five
hundred forty one thousand two hundred
and twenty so two million five hundred
sixty one thousand three hundred twenty
we'll write that down here so we know
how much we spent total so now
we'll see how much exactly we made okay
so it's the exact number so two million
seven hundred and eighteen thousand
minus what we spent
so 156,000 so that's how much money we
made
you
now I wrote that down so 60 divided by
5.5 because it took five and half
minutes equals ten point nine so what
times that by how much we made and 1.7
million ml doing this and also get
60,000 magic experience per hour more
realistically because it takes a little
bit of time you're going to be making at
least one mil an hour but you can make
up to 1.7 milk and even more when the
barges are high thanks for watching guys
and stay tuned for next video
[Music]